Les vacances au bord de la mer !
Ça fait du bien...
Enfin là, c'est l'océan Atlantique.
On va la goûter ? Il paraît qu'elle est bonne.
Pouah ! Elle est vraiment salée !
Je m'y ferai jamais
Qu'est ce qu'il y à là dedans ?
On va chez moi.
L'eau de mer contient en moyenne
35 grammes de sel par litre.
En moyenne... Parce qu'il y a de fortes variations.
35 grammes dans l'Atlantique nord,
38 dans la mer Méditerranée,
jusqu'à 260 grammes de sel par litre
dans la mer Morte,
moins de 10 dans la mer Baltique.
C'est essentiellement
du chlorure de sodium
NaCl pour ceux qui ont
des atomes crochus avec la chimie.
Un ion sodium, autrement dit,
un atome de sodium qui a perdu un électron
combiné avec un ion chlorure, autrement dit,
un atome de chlore qui a gagné un électron.
Du sel de table,
celui qu'on met sur les frites,
pour ceux
qui préfèrent la cuisine.
Attention !
Dans l'eau, chlorure et sodium
naviguent séparément.
Oh là... Il faudra mettre
un peu d'huile !
Ils ne se combinent,
pour former des cristaux de sel,
que lorsque l'eau s'évapore.
À ce moment-là,
ils mettent en commun un électron.
L' électron que l'ion chlorure
possède en trop
et qui manque cruellement
à l'ion sodium.
Une belle leçon
de solidarité !
D'où vient ce sel ?
De très loin... dans le temps.
Ces composants se sont formés
il y a 4 milliards d'années
quand la Terre était
toute jeune.
Pour mémoire, elle s'est formée
il y à 4,6 milliards d'années.
À l'époque, évidemment,
elle n'avait pas du tout la même physionomie.
Il y a 4 milliards d'années, la Terre est
recouverte de volcans en activité
qui libèrent de la vapeur d'eau et des gaz.
Des gaz qui contiennent du soufre et du chlore.
Quand la pluie commence à tomber
et à former les océans,
ces gaz vont se dissoudre dans l'eau.
Si à l'époque on avait goûté l'eau des océans,
elle aurait déjà eu un petit goût salé.
Car dans le tandem chlorure de sodium,
c'est le chlorure qui donne le goût salé.
Le sodium, lui, rend les papilles plus
sensibles. Il arrive dans la foulée.
C'est un des éléments des roches
qui recouvrent notre planète
comme le potassium,
le magnésium ou le calcium.
Ces éléments ont été arrachés
par le ruissellement de l'eau de pluie
et transportés
jusqu'aux océans.
Le phénomène
se poursuit aujourd'hui.
Des cours d'eau,
comme celui-ci,
déversent ces éléments
dans les mers et dans les océans.
Chaque année,
plus de 2 milliards de tonnes.
Alors, me direz-vous, avec tout cela,
pourquoi la salinité n'augmente-t-elle pas ?
Eh bien tout simplement parce que ces éléments
sont absorbés par l'environnement.
Le potassium, par exemple,
par l'argile très présent au fond des océans,
le calcium par les organismes marins
et le sodium par les roches volcaniques.
Du coup, la salinité n'augmente pas !
Pouah ! Je confirme ça n'a pas bougé
depuis le début de la vidéo.
Elle est toujours aussi salée !
Impossible de la boire et surtout
impossible de se réhydrater avec cette eau.
C'est une histoire d' équilibre !
L'organisme est constitué de cellules,
des centaines de milliards.
Chaque cellule contient entre autres
de l'eau - H2O - et des sels minéraux.
Quand on mange un aliment salé,
le sel se disperse dans les tissus.
Il se retrouve dissous dans l'eau
où baignent les cellules.
À ce moment là, il y a davantage de sel
à l'extérieur qu'à l'intérieur de la cellule.
Pour rééquilibrer la concentration en sel,
l'eau contenue dans les cellules
migrent vers l'extérieur.
Pour dissoudre davantage le sel.
Privée d'eau, la cellule
est encore plus déshydratée
et nous avons encore plus soif !
Voilà pourquoi on ne peut pas s'hydrater
avec l'eau de mer.
En fait, l'eau de mer; c'est bien pour
nager ou pour barboter.
Je vais peut-être
rester un peu ici moi !
Allez ! À très bientôt et pour le prochain sujet,
je préfère rester un peu vague.
Allez à très bientôt et
pour le proçain chujet !
blablabla !
blablabla
Prochain sujet
Là ? Je suis dans le champ ?
Ok donc on fait ça !
Là je suis dans le champ, ok bon !